three Russian servicemen delivering
humanitarian aid have been killed in a
terrorist ambush in Syria artis done in
Hawkins has details incident in question
they actually took place back at the end
of February in the eastern Syrian
province of Deir Ezzor where fighting
against Islamic state militants as well
as other terrorist groups has been very
active indeed for the past few weeks and
months
this operation there was a delivery of
humanitarian aid by Russian troops to
one of the towns in that province it was
on the way back from that delivery to
their base when they were ambushed by a
group of militants in their vehicle and
declared missing in action as a result
of the subsequent firefight now since
then the Russian Ministry when the stand
has undertaken round-the-clock efforts
to locate those servicemen and to
establish their fate they did this with
conjunction with allies from the Syrian
Defense Forces as well as other channels
as well and it was as a result of these
efforts that the group involved in this
attack was identified a special
operations forces Special Forces
operation was launched by the Russian
army in conjunction with the Russian Air
Force 30 militants from that terrorists
who were eliminated as a result sadly it
was confirmed though that those three
troops were killed in action as a result
of their ambush their bodies have now
been returned to Russia and returned to
their families
you